How do we boost a number of different coverage metrics?
I’d like to return to a topic that I discussed at the beginning of this unit which is the input domain.
What coverage is letting us do is divide up the input domain into regions in such a way,
for any given region, any test input in that region, will accomplish some specific coverage task.
Any input that we select within this particular region of the input domain
will cause a particular statement or line to execute, cause the branch to execute in some
specific direction, execute a loop zero times, one time, or more, etc.
And so, the obvious problem is, if we partition the input domain this way
and we go ahead and test, it is easier for me to reach the region in the input domain,
we’re going to get good coverage, but we’re not going to be able to do is find areas of omission.
That is to say, nothing about this process of selecting points in the input domain and testing them
in order to achieve good coverage is going to let us discover of what we haven’t implement.
So, let me give a quick example--so, typically, as we talk about unit too, the software under test
is using APIs provided by the system.
Perhaps, the system under test is creating files on the hard disc.
One extremely possible kind of bug that we would put in to the system under test
is failing to check error codes that could be returned from file creation operations
that happen when the disc is full or when there is a hard disc failure or something like that.
And so, what I really mean here is that, for example,
we got a full branch coverage of the system under test but there just isn’t a branch in the test
that should have been taken when the hard disc returns an error code.
And so, if the branch that should be there isn’t there, when the disc does return an error code,
something weird is going to happen, the software is going to fail.
So, the fundamental fact here is that coverage metrics are not particularly good
at discovering areas of omission like missing error checks.
To discover those, we need to use other methods.
So, for example, we discussed fault injection where we make the disc fail,
we will make it send something bad up to the system and we see what happens,
and in that case, if we’re missing an error check, then the system should actually do the wrong thing
and will be able to discover this by watching the system misbehave.
Another thing we could have done is partition the input domain in a different way.
That is to say not partition the input domain using an automated coverage metrics
rather partition the input domain using the specification.
So, if we partitioning input domain based on the specification
and the specification mentions the need for our system to respond gracefully to disc errors,
there is going to be some little corner of the input space
that is triggered only when disc fail and while we test that.
So the point that I’m getting to here is that there are multiple ways
of partitioning the input domain for purposes of testing.
Partitioning the input domain based on features of the code
is one way and it happens to be quite effective in general,
but since I can’t find the areas of omission, we also want sample the input domain in different ways.
We also want to sample the input domain in other ways
and that’s the team that we will return to a full force in units four, five, and six.
All right, so that wraps up our quick survey of test coverage metrics.